[Music]
everyone i'm denny director welcome to
the daily denny live it's Thursday which
means we're live but I'm so excited
because we have a very very special
guest
you know her from 13 reasons why
acrimony Empire and starting Friday
you'll know her as Gabrielle Union's
daughter and breaking in please welcome
Asiana Alexis beautiful and talented
that list of credits
that's just recent credits yeah well
thanks for joining us
you guys have you have any questions for
Queen a over here let us know in the
comments section we'll get into this
iPad but first we need to talk about
breaking in cuz I watched it and I was
telling you earlier I was sitting there
eating my popcorn like all stressed out
it was everything I wanted to be like so
suspenseful so fun you were brilliant in
it so when you get the call that you're
gonna be Gabrielle union's daughter your
reaction is yeah well I was so excited I
was actually filming 13 reasons why at
the time and so it was really hard cuz I
was doing 13 reasons why acrimony and
Empire and so I was like oh I don't know
not for me but my team was like her
schedule is so crazy like what can you
guys do and I was so blessed because gab
and all the producers they just really
really really wanted me for this part so
they did whatever they could to
accommodate the schedule and so it was a
ongoing process like I thought it was
gonna conflict but then they made it
work I mean already working on Empire
with taraji and of course 13 reasons why
I blew up I mean it must feel real good
to know Gabrielle Union it's like we'll
wait for her like she was she's a big
fan of 30v that's why I was like when we
saw each other is like I love yous like
now I love you you know and so it was
like one of those big sister moments I
love that worked out perfect you know
you mentioned Gabrielle loves 13 reasons
why I mean I imagined that she was
someone you looked up to you I mean
she's been in a game for a really long
time
you know surprising she's so real and
she's so humble and down-to-earth and I
think the industry needs more people
like her you know it doesn't matter how
big you get or what you get on it's like
you have so much you can learn from
everybody no matter their age what they
do if they're actress or not or you know
how successful they are and that's how
she is and I think that's why she's so
successful because she gets it humble
about it and she you know she loves her
co-stars yeah she was talking to us
about bring it on from back in the day
she still has so much admiration and 10
Things I Hate About You the people she
works you know and in fact we have a
little surprise for you our Kevin
Frazier asked Gabriel about working with
you and she was gushing gushing gushing
you want to play it for you
save your reaction though because
they're like be able to see it but you
love Asiana yeah you you you saw her
she's delicious she's like one of my
favorite people
she is amazing in this mood because
she's like it's almost like you give her
power in this movie or she or she comes
into her power like sometimes we don't
know it as younger people
they you know think you had it all along
Dorothy you just you know you just click
your heels
she's been work she's been a working
actress since I think she was like 13 so
she she's been doping amazing and and
you know paid and and you know a diva
for a long time but didn't know she had
that superstar in her and I just was
like you know I'm just the cheerleader
I'm hyping her up I'm spliff star I'm
like hey you better watch you know I
love her but I like her in 13 reasons
why that's where I saw her and she just
shines she shines laughter this is every
day like I laughed so hard like I know
her so well you know what you know so it
is the smallest things like that video
loan like represents us and just how we
talk to each other so so funny it's like
it's like when colleagues and co-workers
become friends yeah exactly so funny I
laugh so hard all the time I have tears
yeah you bet oh wow
but off to get to here what's something
you learned from working with Gabby and
maybe just even being in their life yeah
I think from her is so much you know we
talked to non-stop and she's so powerful
she's strong she's smart and one thing
she that really stuck with me is that
she was an actress and also producer on
the show and I recommend her that for
that because she understands both sides
and she told me you know never feel
limited like just because you're an
actress there's so much more to that so
don't feel like oh you know you know you
have to be humble and understand there's
just so many platforms you can take over
in one so don't be limited to just one
thing know that you're capable to do
everything at once
well said that's a good mentor to have
huh yeah so in the movie you know
obviously Gabrielle's character she goes
into mama bear mode maybe even hyper
like mama bear right but you have some
badass moments for yourself which I
wasn't expecting what was that training
like for you know weed moment you know
yeah we didn't really do training we had
a stunt coordinator who was there so
he'd be like you know delenn just kind
of give you tips but me I grew up like a
tomboy so I was like ooh let's do it you
know it's just like let's try it I just
kind of jumped into it and I think you
know something gaps at before with these
roles it's like we're just an average
normal family so it's not something we
should have necessarily trained for
because it becomes something like okay
what are you doing the moments to
survive so you're not gonna be like
backflip perfect you know you're just
gonna do what you need to do and so I
think it's kind of good that we didn't
train as much on it so it can come off
more realistic I mean when the action
starts her character's barefoot so
you're right like she's real normal she
actually told us about that too she was
saying that she didn't had to do much
training she just did Pilates and
drinking my Rosa it was some Rinella but
okay so let's talk about 13 reasons why
obviously that first season really
really took off and season two's just
around the corner I know it's shrouded
in secrecy but what we do know is that
you this next batch of episodes will
focus on serial sexual abuse right yeah
so how does the show tackle that issue I
mean I feel like it tackles it in a lot
of ways and not only that but it's so
many other issues that's just around
that so
but I think what's more important is
that you see all sides of the spectrum
from different characters because like
he says when it comes to someone being
sexually abused there's so many people
involved and so many people who get
affected by it so I think a way that's
smart that they're handling it is
showing like other people's and their
point of views and how they're being
corrupted and how it kind of interferes
with their lifestyle because I want the
world to not it's not so many Hanna
Baker's there's Marcus's there's
Sheree's there's teachers and you know
so it's it's good that they're showing
other sides of the stories as well I was
gonna say they really give each of you
guys so much to work with and not just
as actors but you also get to send such
so many different kinds of messages to
so many different people I met I bet
that feels for you as an actress like
the cherry on top of a sundae right
because you have the job opportunity but
now you have a responsibility it's
awesome yeah for sure and you know one
thing for me I've been doing this for a
long time so I I always make sure I take
on roles that that serves my purpose of
what I want my career to serve and so I
don't just take anything and so it has
to be something that's kind of I feel
will benefit the world in a way and
young adolescents and so like you say to
be able to do something I love and have
a responsibility and get that across as
a blessing it's like you're getting your
job done but also serving things for a
higher purpose and reality of life it's
such a heavy subject matter but you look
like you're having fun too much have you
guys bonded over this experience yeah I
think first season was so fun we went
out of high you know we're not two
dinners second season it was a little
different because we had more of a fan
base and so especially out in San
Francisco like it's so small you go to
one little area somebody takes a picture
in this literally crowds coming and
we're like we're gonna yeah yeah so it
gets a little hectic sometimes so I feel
like season two was more secluded and
then we were more so in houses and our
hotels and stuff like that but it was
still really fun because had each other
to Kelly super dope what's one word you
would use to describe season two of 13
reasons why hmm
plot twist okay yeah so you guys might
be teeing it up for another season huh
I'm down the universe because I'm trying
to manifest back you know something tell
y'all gonna get it oh yeah you mentioned
gabrielle was a fan of 13 reasons why we
should try to get any scoop out of you
you know something yes you do I haven't
even read this because they give it to
us yeah I was shooting thirteen and so
they give us the scripts as we go in
this constantly changing so like we're
at our table reason we're like oh my god
it's like we're figuring it figuring it
out as we go and we're filming it is
exciting I can't wait to watch that I'm
a binge it yes thank you thanks for
putting all those episodes up at once
that I'm not trying to waste any time so
you know you worked with taraji P Henson
on Empire acrimony and I of course
Gabrielle Union who's on your list of
like dream co-stars let's put it up so
many people you know I look up to so
many different people for different
reasons and I feel like there's just so
many people I can learn from even people
I don't know but he's always saw Donna I
love her she's gained our on the Walk of
Fame today I think she's amazing Cameron
Diaz Rachel McAdams Joan Rivers what's
the lady that was on American Horror
Story oh Jessica Lane yes directors on
your radar there's so many yeah I've had
a blessing that's what I love about this
series we work with so many different
directors writers so you get like a lot
of learning experience too of how
different people are working so if that
wasn't enough all these acting roles now
today called baggage look you tell us
about it so back is just like for me
because it shows my side of like savage
and then also like the sensitive savage
side so the whole album itself is gonna
be called savage and so baggage I
decided to release this one first
because I feel like so many people can
relate to it it's like everyone comes
along with baggage everyone comes along
with some insecurities some problems
like it's just so much you know and you
have to find that one person who's
willing to kind of take that in for you
and I think especially as a woman like
they think we just were supposed to be
the little house
Housewives and I'm like you know I come
along with more baggage than you think
that just a pretty face I think just
with anybody there's always like a turn
to them and so it's the baggage so it's
like can you handle it yes sir our Torah
I'm gonna be bumping it all weekend
we're gonna play a little bit for you
guys but I was saying this is my new jam
for the weekend she goes play it for
your friend and leave and your exits so
you got something to get across in this
the universe when you are seeking when
you were a coordinator were you thinking
of someone in particular
I wrote this so fast it started off fun
actually but everyone's have something
to do with my life a hundred percent in
one person or a different person or like
four people at a time so it's all very
personal to me for sure it's queen they
put a little sass on it huh all right
well we got a special treat for your
fans right now we have an exclusive
first look at the lyric video for
baggage it drops later today but we got
a taste for you guys now take a look no
you got baggage no you got back in I
know you got baggage you got baggage I
know you got secrets no you got secret
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow you'll see my dancing side and
performance level so that was you know
chill fun stuff and the full video is
gonna drop today right and you guys can
stream and download and buy the song now
right not now yeah cuz I wanted to do
something just special to show people
you know my appreciation for their
support and so for this one it's like
people haven't heard my music side so I
want them to just to get a feel of Who I
am then when the whole project comes out
they can definitely make sure you're
following around socials then so you
guys can see when that all drops so I'm
expecting or we are we expecting like a
full record for album oh yeah sure I
have it it's all done I've been riding a
lot lately probably just more like an EP
just like this six seven songs so people
can like get a feel of who I am but I've
been writing so much and this is okay if
you love baggage you're gonna love these
that is baggage like a taste of what we
can expect from the full thing is that
the visor baggage so like I was saying
it's like two sides so I have the savage
side me it's like baggage you know sassy
like attitude and then I have the savage
side that's my bougie way of self so
it's like more so real singing and like
real vocals and melodic like melodies
for pianos and guitars so you get two
sides of me as an artist so I'm really
excited it's like Monday through Friday
gosh yes you're right and then come
Saturday music inspirations so many
people Beyonce for sure you know just
when it comes to performance levels in
giving that visual Michael Jackson Janet
Jackson Ciara I could go on for days I
love a deal as far as her writing style
and via her writing style but I mean
there's so many people who who inspires
me even underground artists that I
listen to you mentioned a lot of artists
who also write and/or produce music how
important is that to you really
important you know I think nowadays
something that's missing with artists is
they're kind of giving this image but
then they're like you're seeing that
using this you do this heat and so it's
hard for them to figure out who they are
as a
as an artist and if you're not true to
yourself that's kind of when you fall
off but when you're true to yourself and
you have your own input and all this
other stuff you you can't help but to go
up because you're not faking it you just
be so genuine and people respond to that
yeah definitely that's something I've
been working every time I'm in the
studio like always making sure I'm a
part of it's like learning okay let's do
this I love see already inspiring all
kinds of young girls out there I love
that in fact Cassie left from YouTube
says love join Empire and love watching
your journey Edward from Facebook does
have a question he wants to know what is
your secret to looking so beautiful have
a team over there there okay whatever
they you know I wake up a little rough
thank you it's my team for sure you know
they put the little things under my
little eyes you know Rihanna actually
just posted a tutorial on Vogue and I
was watching that it's so funny it's
like you just got to learn the tips and
tricks from everyone but I feel like
they figured it out it's hard to find
people who knows your faces you know
what I mean so we find that squad is
like module alright so obviously you've
been part of so many amazing amazing
projects and this is just the beginning
for you really
what has this last year two years meant
to you
Wow so much I mean like I've started
since I was six years old I put a lot of
work into this so it's not overnight
success and I feel like it's more so the
world is just now seeing what I'm
capable of and kind of taking it into
their perspective but for me I have see
the bigger vision and the bigger goals
of everything so I think something I
have a problem with is actually
celebrating my success and the few
things that I do do because I see this
and I'm like oh thank you that's great
all right what are we don't like I'm
always you know kind of so I have to
learn how to live more in that moment of
things but I mean it's a blessing but
it's also just the beginning so I'm very
humbled by it seems like you've been
waiting and prepared for this moment for
so long you know it's like what Oprah
says it's when preparation and
opportunity me and so it doesn't it
not like a it's more like I've worked
for this you start coming you put in the
work now you have to keep going more
than ever it's more important it's most
importantly it's like what are you doing
after this like don't get too caught up
in to what was happening because that
can be here and gone any day now I know
you're really focused on your career but
Sarah just sent a question first of all
she says you're so beautiful and you
have so much going on do you have time
to date with your busy schedule I'm a
lonely little soul I don't you know live
my life I have a few people you know I
talk to here in there but never know but
I give away any names because you want
to keep that mystery yeah I'm very a
solo dolo person though you know like
MySpace I'm really focused you know I
have so much going on so not to say boys
are distractions but myself right now go
collect your coin first you know
collector coin well anyways it was so
lovely chat with you thank you so much
for being here you guys breaking in is
in theaters tomorrow I'm telling you
you're gonna have a blast it's that
popcorn flick I'm telling ya I know
there's a bunch of superhero movies but
Gabrielle Union and Asiana they are
super heroes in this movie so go check
it out you guys thanks make sure you
follow her on social and tomorrow we'll
be back with a brand new daily Danny so
thank you guys for watching and we'll
see you then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]